hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trading senses.com so in this video i
would like to take a look at some very
interesting cryptocurrencies uh where we
have some very nice situation so let's
have a look at all of this let's get
into it
[Music]
all right so i'm gonna start with axs so
as usual what we're gonna do here we're
gonna use the usual technical analysis
tools that we have which is audio12
counting divergences fib ratios and
extensions and breakouts and trendlines
of course
so here the first thing i do i check on
the first time frame and i check all the
data so basically this is a
cryptocurrency that is just going higher
all right since november 20. so then i'm
trying to do some counting and you can
see that here the counting is pretty
obvious so in yellow one two three four
so we are doing a fifth and in each
motif wave guys i can subdivide each
movement into five waves so one two
three four five then abc corrective wave
then one two three four five so right
now to me it looks like we are in a
fixed wave we just broke out the
all-time high
at 52 and
it's pretty tough for me to buy here but
you know you have different type of
trading for example
right now on my discord guys there is a
gabrielle that joined the trading team
and he has some techniques that are
different from mines
which i really like and i'm pretty sure
he would be buying this i would be
waiting but you know what i can tell you
is that you know maybe a good thing to
do here is just to buy 50 of the total
position you want to have and to buy the
second half on the retest you know and
just to put a stop loss right below now
in terms of targets here fib extension
don't work at all right let me show you
if you measure for example here one plus
three and you apply to the bottom of the
force you can see that we are already
above four times the 1.618 so this is
just too explosive for field extensions
to be applied so we can only rely on
basic trendline methods that basically
assume that there's going to be the same
growth potential once again here i am in
the log scale so it means that the gross
percentage would be the same between
november 20 and april 21 then between
april 21 and i don't know for example
september
uh so my target would be here for this
cryptocurrency once again maybe we're
going to have a pullback maybe not but
let's assume we go from here i think
this can take like around 150
guys in a matter of a few weeks so this
is a very very nice opportunity
all right next one
uh a d a so what do we have here same
thing guys let's have a look at that
so we have here it's starting much
earlier all right so here we have the
downtrend created by the bitcoin drop
that happened in 2018 and now we're
going higher together with the bitcoin
so by the way this is very correlated to
the bitcoin that is also in a fifth wave
so i'm a buyer at 42 500 personally on
the bitcoin so this all is like kind of
related all right this goes together and
here is the same thing we have the fifth
wave so one two three with the third
wave being extended one two three four
five four's corrective wave that comes
exactly guys so it's always interesting
to notice you know some people you know
say you cannot apply technical analysis
to cryptocurrency market all right so
can anyone explain to me why we are
having this perfect consolidation on the
moving average all right it's because
you have a lot of traders that are
buying there that's it and so here now
the situation is quite good guys because
we have this breakout
we are still close to it so i think that
there is a nice opportunity here to get
in and to play this fifth wave all right
the kind of thing i would do here we are
close to the breakout area and you can
see that we had a lot of consolidation
guys so whenever you have this kind of
consolidation and this is the type of
things that i would try to explain to
you guys if you join me on discord once
again let me uh here repeat what i'm
trying to do there i'm taking a big risk
right and my associate is not happy
about that i can tell you because you
know he was just telling me hey bro you
know you keep you quit your job you can
just try to you know basically sell some
trainings on youtube you have a lot of
viewers blah blah blah and i was like
man i'm a trader i want to trade i want
to you know use my techniques that i've
been using for a long time i want to use
it in front of people and show them that
i'm not just a youtuber but i'm a trader
so this is what i'm trying to do here we
starting live training it's september
guys in few weeks so if you want to join
the movement it's still time you can
click on the link in description of this
video and there are still a 25
off for one more week even less a few
days only so join the movement now if
you're interested and over there i'm
gonna take a lot of trends and this is
the typical one i would take all right
so i'm not sure we're gonna trade crypto
but there are a lot of stocks
that actually follow the crypto market
and here there is a very nice
opportunity so i would be a buyer here
around 48
billion you know
very high 48 billion and you know i
would stop loss just below here the 200
period moving average that is acting
perfectly yes as support so whenever you
have this kind of reactions you need to
use it right here it's too beautiful not
to be used and in terms of targets we
are going to first let's see if the fib
applied well here all right one to one
relation not bad
so i can apply fib extensions from the
first wave here the beginning of the
first wave to the top of the third and
i'm going to assume that my target is
the 1.618 so we go 260 billion so it's
times three so you have a very limited
risk for a very nice reward and this is
the type of trades that you want to be
in next one let's do the ripple xrp all
right so what do we have here same thing
guys i start in 2017
and i can see first thing i notice is
that moves up develop very well in five
ways one two three four five i mean at
least here then the correction was here
very messy
it's not even possible to label it using
elliott wave theory but uh definitely it
was a trend line all right so whenever
elliot wave is not working we have other
tools that are going to help us to you
know to get this kind of signal so here
you can see so once again i'm not
following the crypto market very closely
so i wasn't there but this is the type
of trend i would get in breakdown retest
i would be a buyer here then i would
have probably taken some profits here
and here i would have reloaded guys we
come back again on this trend line that
has been you know very obvious okay for
the past three years one two three
four four reactions then break out so
fifth six seven
seven reactions guys in a few years so
of course you take the eighth one and
you buy here stop loss just below so
this would have worked and now what is
happening to me we had a first wave here
one two three four five correction one
two three four five
i can label it if you want
all right
okay one two three four five here same
one two three four five okay and i guess
we gonna have a one two three four five
again guys all right it's starting like
this
so it would make sense to me and in
terms of ratios of targets as usual you
measure one plus three you applied to
the bottom of the force it gives you 3.5
all right so this is a very ambitious
target of course if you get in this
trade at this level you need to start
taking profits much earlier
and maybe get back in if things go well
so for example at 1.1 1.7 those kind of
levels you would be willing taking some
profits there and the last one luna so
to the moon i mean the name looks great
to me same thing we have a very limited
amount of data here so what can we do
only apply the basic things guys move up
let's try to find five ways one two
three four five works pretty well for me
here we measure one plus three we
applied to the bottom of the force oh
surprise it works it has worked very
well here it gave us the 18 level so we
went to 22 all right as a target for the
fifth wave so i'm happy to see that when
i see that i'm confident to use it again
i'm like all right this market is
respecting elliot wave rules so we can
uh you know take advantage of this
situation by using it again and here we
have the typical abc correction and it
looks very well to me like we are
starting a new move up guys all right
so bam bam bam abc
one two three four five something like
this so this target is of course very
approximative here i cannot have real
target because we only had the first
wave second wave and here guys i mean
it's the right time to get in here we
just had the breakout and as you can see
as 80 90 percent of the time it has been
re-tested especially when we come from
far and we didn't have this build up
consolidation phase so here the
likeliness to be retested is close to
100
and we had the retest here we might have
one more all right so if you don't want
to buy ex here you can wait for one more
but maybe you're going to wait and never
get in here i think it's a nice
opportunity to get in because you know
we are just above the breakout so this
is the type of chess that i would keep
an eye on i would monitor this for you
guys i'm building some excel
spreadsheets with uh gabriel who is uh
the trader that is going to work with me
who has a lot of experience who is very
very full of knowledge so it's very
interesting and exciting for me to work
with him uh he suggested me to actually
analyze those uh cryptocurrencies and uh
it's
all looking very nice to me so i hope
you guys gonna enjoy that i hope you
enjoyed this analysis so uh that i
managed to explain to you how i use my
tools how i check if they are efficient
or not before using them and taking my
trades so if you did enjoy this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys